welcome to this video Quattro princesses
are those the four princes for Prince
Princess us probably female I don't have
any knowledge of spanish being just one
week on my yoga where I was yeah not not
much further than ordering some coffee
okay we have the night off and then
playing a sideline do you go clean three
here or capture first maybe you capture
first and then 23 that's a sideline but
quite quite okay for white very safe
line white quickly get some pressure
against the pawn yes and very often you
get this this type of position which is
slightly very slightly more comfortable
for white because some white very often
gets the Bishop to d3 okay so he wants
to he wants to play a d3 here Queen f.3d
three and made on be to the sir this
kind of idea ok the question is um what
do i do against this
I can try g45 you can play rook c8 maybe
rook c8 c3
g45 bubble tea for rook c8
yeah i can i can start with this at
least yeah rooks III ok
okay come on let's play a dry game here
with queen bee three
if anything white some edges very
miniscule if it takes but at least it's
is easy to play
radius f/4g 5 and he can rarely take on
d5 without activating my be sure i know
i don't have anything anything special
him but after this bad losing streak i
welcome some some safety let's say
yeah Luke t5g five returns bishop be 434
for a good position even so this wasn't
too successful this will be fine idea at
least this verse this is what I was
thinking turnout take you for him well
that's comfortable route you one looks
very normal maybe I can make sure that
the rook here is not really coming out
with be for c3 does this type of stuff
maybe I can also try to play on the
e-file or Bishop Bishop g5 it's also
nice should be five and try to do
something on the Kings side but ok let's
let's start with this try to gain some
spatium
no yeah this this was possible but I
thought that this this pressure on f7
would prove to be proved to be a problem
now look this 7 coming the bishop on b3
is obviously far more dangerous than his
bishop SB 3 as directed directly against
the against the King on the Kings side
jana this is a very awkward pen group d
8 threatened don't really see how he how
he can resolve this black resides yep
this this was quickly going downhill
after this Ricky five idea I mean here
it's really it's really not much going
on that so this is a bit more
comfortable for white I have some some
more ideas but it's really just equal
but this is leading into leading use
some trouble because I gained some space
at least and he should really not take
after that I've made some some big
progress and now I playing this this
supper yes a perm sub pawn bishop d5 is
better yeah I just angel I should block
this this is it keeps an edge but I
should play Bishop b5 it's better but
this is a very good positioner anyway i
get to i get to d7 there's no way around
that the main line here given by stock
fishes this which is frankly speaking
quite terrible for black I just I just
gave gain air just whenever it's
probably very close to win even
yeah it's just not good I mean he
shouldn't really do this Luke takes d5
because it directly gives my my bishop
you just juice scope getting to d5 it
was really very quickly going down the
drain rookie 3 is still still okay I
mean this is this kind of position is a
bit more comfortable for me but I
shouldn't really like wind quickly so
this is what you should do okay thanks
for watching